welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video are
breaking down The Last of Us Part
[Music]
three we have some plot details rumors
and also lots of theories about what's
going to be going on in the upcoming
game there will be heavy spoilers here
in regards to part two so if this is
your first time going through the
remaster or something then I suggest you
switch your game up and head off like
Ellie did to Seattle after Abby got a j
in One spoilers already dear me but
please hit the Thumbs Up Button if you
enjoy the video without the way thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
The Last of Us Part three okay so first
up we have to say that the game hasn't
been officially announced yet Neil dman
did say to the script A Part podcast
that the writing on the story had been
finished though but they just hadn't put
it into development yet since then
though Daniel rpk has kept people in the
loop and said that the game indeed's
being worked on right now it makes sense
too as there's definitely directions
they could take things and Daniel's even
brought us some plot details as well
full disclaimer I've known Daniel for a
couple of years and the guy's always
been pretty spot on when it comes to
leaks I'm signed up to his patreon and
it's helped me a lot cuz the guy's
gotten so many things right when it
comes to behind the scenes stuff so
meant that we could prepare for trailers
clear out the schedule and all in all I
trust the guy heavily for example he
call that Caitlyn Diva was going to be
playing Abby months and months before it
was announced and therefore I think you
know we should pay attention to what he
says so that's why I want to dive into
it because I think there's a lot of way
to these leaks now Daniel deals in a lot
of casting grades and he posted the
following plot lines and also character
names who part of the plot will be about
a group of scavengers surviving on the
outskirts of a post-apocalyptic City
crammed into a Victorian house that
serves as their base they are looking to
cast these roles Bal female leader of
the group Ezra male who wants to take
over the house from Val Mason male a
former Soldier when Val gets put in
charge mayus choose between his loyalty
to Ezra and the house Lucas male affable
but develops a relationship with another
scavenger and will have a turn that
shows his Dark Side Gracie female 18 to
25 no other details on this character
now makes me wonder if they're going to
be retooling the factions game as it has
been recently announced that that whole
thing's canceled potentially they might
take elements of that though and reskin
certain things to build it into a bigger
plot now since this release there's been
lots of different theories and people
spec ulating about where it could go
Luke Stevens recently put out a big
video talking about what he thought the
game could be Luke said he thinks it
would be great if we grew to know these
characters and then we saw Tommy and
Joel show up at the house this would
reveal the game's actually a prequel
setting between the 20 years between
outbreak day when he met Ellie I think
that would be such a good rug pull and
as we know Joel and Tommy did a lot of
dark things they've often paid lip
service to what they did for surviving
and I think it would be great to see
that from another perspective having
Joel sharp and be some many your face
off against would be a cool way to take
things and I think that's what's always
been at the heart of the series though
we all love Joel if you view Things From
Another point of view you can definitely
see how he'd be the bad guy I think
exploring why him and Tommy fell out as
well would be a good way to take things
as would flash out their backstory and
show why Tommy joined the fireflies they
showing things from different
perspectives is pretty much what the
point of the second game was but I think
they fumbled the ball with how it was
presented now whenever I've talked about
the last of a season 2 on our podcast
I've brought up how think they should do
the show personally I think they should
show things from Abby's perspective from
the off and through a couple of episodes
we really get to know her then we learn
that Joel killed a dad and we either end
an episode of the season with her
killing him this would make us get us
attached to her first which is something
I think that the game messed up though I
love part two I have to admit it took a
while and pretty early on I was annoyed
by how they handled it in the end I grew
to really like Abby but it took me
basically having to walk a mile or or
several miles in her shoes that's what
they're trying to do obviously but I
think having that happen first would be
a better way to handle it say part two
had have started off from her
perspective and we then made our way
across America to Jackson this track
would let you really get to know her and
then you'd have more of a split when she
finally kills Joel the way they handled
it initially I was ready to just say
[__] and I know a lot of players that
didn't even give her a chance that's why
I think the house us that it could work
so well though and they could make us
attach to it before someone we know
rolls through we then be wanting to
protect it especially if we'd finally
taken it from Val and yeah I hope they
do something creative with the premise
now another few time few Time new time
time I've come up with so copyright this
F Theory right copyright it is that
these names are simply just placeholders
a lot of the times when they're putting
out casting calls they often hide names
not to give things away you'll see this
when they're casting and you get like
we're looking for a Ry goling type to
play someone known as Bert then it turns
out to be someone like Adam Warlock and
Studios do this in order to hide details
I was thinking that what they might do
is actually tell the origins of the sah
fight in part two we got a tease of
their profit but it was a bit weird cuz
we never got to meet her throughout
playing it I constantly thought it was
teasing a boss battle or something and
that the buildup was going to PVE the
way to fighting her never happened
though cuz while she was executed which
we learn happened by the wlf the
soldiers captured her and Isaac thought
she was too dangerous and thus the
leader had her put down this made her a
modder but I'd love to see her r and how
she became a legend Isaac is sort of a
similar character too cuz the second
game teased him a lot as well he's
another who I thought would lead to a
big battle but in the end he just got
killed on the island Skirmish so
learning either of their Origins would
be such a cool way to take things and
I'd love to have the gaml out where he
can maybe swap between the pair anyway
that's it
you now Jeffrey PS has also been asked
about the game and he acted a bit Co in
case you don't know he played Tommy in
part one and part two and also played
Perry in the show in an interview with
Dextero he said at this point it's not
something that to be in any fashion at
least not that I know of and I would
hate to set up myself to have
expectations about what it would be and
then have it be something completely
different the article end says however
Pier was quick to add that he has full
faith in director Neil dman and knows
that when he does receive a script for
part three that it will be perfect I'm
going to trust when Neil hands me a
script that it's going to be perfect
because that's the way it's been up
until now and when that happens and a
asked about last of part three I have to
say I have no idea what you're talking
about so yeah guys in full Andrew
Garfield mode but it makes me think that
he knows more than he's letting on so
what we're going to do is get him and
Neil dman and then tie the pair to
chairs I'm then going to hold up a piece
of paper with is The Last of Us three
coming and you tick the Box yes or no
and it better be the same tick that your
make gives that's a joke mate hey bloody
can't say anything these days without
threatening people but hope you've
enjoyed us giving our theories on it I
think the flashback thing is a bit out
there and I would of course also love to
see the continuation of Ali and aby's
story we did a video last year where we
talked about my theories on where they
could take that and there's lots of
things in part two that tease where Abby
could end up going I'm kind of in two
minds where I want a prequel Sequel and
I'd love to see if Alie showed up to the
house too we of course ended with her
going off on her own and though it
seemed like she was heading to Jackson
you just don't know on the director's
commentary they talked about the final
scene and how Dina purposely left all of
Ellie stuff in the house it's cuz she
didn't really want to be with her and
yeah I think the tone of The Last of Us
is that they won't get a happy ending so
seeing allly going through America and
then coming across his house would be
such an interesting way to take things
in the future anyway I'd love to hear
your thoughts so make sure you drop them
below please hit the thumbs up and if
you want to support the channel as a
member of the spoiler Society then
please click the join button you get
early access to videos every week and it
goes such a long way to helping us out
going to get some heavy spoilers MO
we've also got our t-shirt line located
below the video that will let you pick
up all kinds of tops like our Theory
Time One Last of Us stuff Marvel te's
and more we Dro new designs on there all
the time too so definitely keep an eye
out and thanks for your support if you
want some else to watch You' got a video
breaking down stranger things season 5
and all the rumors that we've heard
about the show definitely head over
there right after this and without the
way huge thank you for clicking this
I've been Paul you been the best and
I'll see you next time take care peace